next it's now a year since brexit took
full effect and the uk left the eu's
single market and customs union the date
came with predictions of disaster for
the british economy but 12 months later
how has the country coped
in december last year as britain readied
itself for a hard brexit prime minister
boris johnson addressed parliament in
his typically confident style
i have absolutely no doubt that from
january the 1st this country is going to
prosper mightily mr speaker
[Applause]
but the reality is the country's woes
began almost immediately britain's
chemicals electrical equipment machinery
metals minerals and textile sectors
became hopelessly entangled in the trade
deals so-called rules of origin
any goods arriving in britain from
abroad and then exported into the eu
incur a customs levy and britain's
supply chains rely on a vast number of
parts sourced from outside the european
union thousands of trucks trying to exit
the uk were tied up in the red tape
it's not good and this situation has
it's for me and too much paperwork too
much
weight weight all the time is weight
this is not not good
then in september the uk's petrol pumps
ran dry fuel deliveries from the eu
stalled and a shortfall of european
drivers who had left britain contributed
to the perfect storm the results
national shortages of foodstuffs and
other retail products independent
economists expect the uk's gross
domestic product to drop by four percent
as a result of brexit in the coming
years exports have already fallen
whereas eu countries have actually
expanded
their exports to the rest of the world
the uk has not we've been performing
very badly
so in that sense at least so far at
least brexit has clearly failed to
deliver
so far the british government has not
been able to deliver its brexit promise
that's why some polls show 60 percent of
britons believe brexit has done more
harm than good
well let's get more on this from our
reporter daniel winter hi daniel the uk
as we've just seen has faced a lot of
challenges over the last 12 months but
how does that compare with all the
predictions
well rob as you probably remember boris
johnson promised sun lit uplands when it
came to brexit but now it seems that
britain is facing more of a winter of
discontent now i tried to find what the
positives were the upsides um were in
this uh whole post-brexit era but um it
seems there are some you know some of
the most dire predictions didn't come
true the pound took a bit of a beating
at first but then recovered afterwards
and the city of london is not currently
a shadow of its former self and all of
the issues that britain has faced are
merely teething problems the prime
minister would say however it's not um
possible to escape the reality that
britain is not yet and has no
visible prospects of becoming a
singapore on the eastern atlantic which
was partly the vision i mean we've seen
that
imports and exports have been a huge
headache for businesses dealing with
britain or from britain um with imports
and exports dropping about 16
um it's even worse for services though
with the uk trade policy observatory
saying that imports and exports and
services to the eu have dropped 37
so one saving grace for johnson is that
covert has obscured the the full impact
of um brexit but um it seems that
britain's haven't got what they were
promised yet
okay daniel winter thank you very much
you